wie games com
und das bedeutet für pixum da ein oder
andere gast aus dem bereich gaming
schaut vorbei und zwar in der speakers
corner jeden tag um 10 uhr auf der
gamescom in zusammenarbeit mit dem
westdeutschen rundfunk und einer der
gäste wird ein sehr erfolgreicher gamer
seien aus der electronic sports league
es ist sascha goody lupp der bei
starcraft oh ja ziemlich weit vorne
liegt und da immer bei den entscheidungs
kämpfen mit mischt er wird mir rede und
antwort stehen und auch die ein oder
andere frage wenn sie kreativ ist von
euch beantworten
in die kommentare schreiben gerne auch
als video antwort eurem video frage
stellen den info text lesen und
ansonsten wären die chancen dann wenn
ihr das alles gemacht habt recht gut aus
also wir sind gespannt auf eure fragen
bis dann